One imagines that perhaps we have
created through society for what is
society butter pattern patterns that
reward behaviors in patterns within us
that are either negligent or detrimental
or toxic or psychopathic.
Do you think of many of the people that
are in positions of power and the
structures that surround them and the
structures that they perpetuate,
that these are the product of negative
malevolent thinking and the kind of
spiritual shift taking place on an
individual level if significantly spread
could bring about the kind of change
that's required and indeed would be
called revolution.
Well,
so when I look at it,
people who are in power,
and it was interesting because I was
listening to your podcast or Peterson
and he and then he was kind of
rationalizing the existence of
hierarchies.
And,
but when I look at actually who forms
the epics of the hierarchy in our
society is largely traumatized people.
Um,
for example,
if you believe you live in a horrible
world,
how are you going to be?
You have to be aggressive,
grandiose,
paranoid,
a selfish.
In other words,
you'd be the president of the United
States because he's the one who said in
so many words that the world is a
horrible place,
and that's the world he lives in.
The Buddha said,
2,500
years ago,
that was a miser,
create the world,
but my contention is that before the
with our minds to create the world that
will create some mines and trump's brain
was formed in a family where he was
demeaned and punished and attacked and
humiliated by his father.
And so he believes he lives in a
horrible world.
That's what he acts out.
And his brother drank himself to death.
So is this traumatized people now his
opponent I could go into that was also
traumatized,
right?
So you're saying that in here,
Hillary Clinton versus Donald Trump,
they were too traumatized people.
Doumergue fighting to govern a
traumatized world.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
And,
and,
and Hillary's drama showed up in when
she had pneumonia,
she wouldn't even acknowledge it because
as a child she'd been taught.
She had to suck up her pain.
She mustn't be vulnerable.
She puts up with the philandering of her
husband who is as much of a,
uh,
explorative women is Donald Trump over,
was just not as egregious about it.
And then she's still justifies it.
And so she,
she,
her messages to become inauthentic and
suck it all up.
And that's her form of trauma.
I can talk about British politics.
Cool.
I could talk about what did everyone.
Now you're on a roll.
I could talk about this repressed
person,
uh,
who was so in denial of own trauma that
she's willing to traumatize the most
vulnerable people in society.
Her name was Margaret Thatcher.
What was head trauma?
Do you think this.
I'm enjoying this.
So you sort of,
a bit like in the Matrix when neo Nazis,
everything's made out a numbers.
You look at people and you see all their
trauma and damage.
See,
that's right.
I saw in her a tremendous oppressed
person.
Um,
I saw then you have a bland faced
schoolboy who's willing to murder
hundreds of thousands of people and
never taken any responsibility for it.
Uh,
and it still doesn't deal with the
impact of it.
His name is Tony Blair,
who's quite willing to go to a bomb drop
son,
drop bombs on,
on,
on Arabs for away,
and they'll do it in,
in,
in the service of lies that if schools
could see through and these are
traumatized people.
Otherwise they couldn't do it.
They wouldn't be that split.
And these are the people that our
society rewards with power.
Well,
that's a sign of a traumatized society.
That's my next book.
It's good that asking to be a smash hit
at one.
Banging to that already.
I got to write it first.
You've done the hot book will come up
with a concept.
The restaurants itself.
Now what about the can we carry on with
this game of.
I'm marking off the powerful because I'm
loving this.
So what can we say like,
uh,
like Barack Obama.
I'm like,
there is a continuum.
Obama.
Obama is a fascinating case going.
People talk about trump is destroying
Obama.
His legacy.
I don't think so.
Trump is Obama's legacy.
Yes.
I read his biography.
He's a person that's very chameleon like
he can,
not deliberately and not even
necessarily consciously a the identify
with whoever,
so so,
so you can sound like a white man or you
can sound like a black man depending on
where he's at.
So he appealed to both,
but I think his biggest,
his biggest sin was to have enrolled a
lot of people in the possibility of
transformation and change without
delivering any of it.
For the moment.
Do you think that the inability of these
individuals to manifest real change is a
demonstration.
What we have are deeply entrenched and
traumatized systems that are predicated
on unconscious choices,
unconscious drives and that the system
cannot,
will not alter itself from within
itself,
but will sustain itself and it's only
sort of new radical ideas that can alter
it well.
Any system is designed in such a way as
to make change impossible.
That that's just the nature of any
organization in the system so that.
So that.
So that doesn't matter what.
Even if Obama came along fully committed
to his agenda,
which I believe on some level he was
sincere book.
That would have been a million reasons
why the system and how the system would
have prevented him from carrying an
agenda,
but let me ask you something.
Were assert something.
Obama got into par,
funded heavily by Wall Street is a
street stupid or do they or do they know
which side they're butter bread is
buttered on.
They knew what they were getting.
They didn't buy into the whole pre
changing kind of thing.
Then you exactly what a what a fast
style and inefficient servant of the
status quo he would be and those
students is again to power.
Then your bills out Wall Street,
he was transferred.
He was responsible for one of the
greatest transfers of wealth upwards in
history and and and,
and,
and so the system you what they were
getting.
It's just that the rest of us,
because we want to believe in the
positive side of his persona because
sucked in the system,
never got sucked in by him.
Why this but wielded clinging to these
narratives that have clearly been
exposed is erroneous.
Why now post trump do we.
Why are we seeing from the liberal
establishment and a sort of a nostalgia
for something that was basically about
15 minutes ago rather than an
acknowledgement and a recognition of the
need for meaningful,
significant change that addresses the
problems of essentially the poor.
Well,
when you look at the,
um,
mean you look at see American politics
or economics,
uh,
Obama was as ready as anybody to kill
people abroad.
Um,
he was as,
as anybody to send troops overseas.
Um,
it's no different than American history
has always been.
Um,
he was smoother about it.
He was more urbane about it.
He was a more articulate about it.
He also knew how to speak to people's
better sides.
Along comes trump,
he's agregious.
He's a highly traumatized,
utterly self unrestrained,
a troubled schoolyard bully.
And so it's offensive to the
sensitivity,
the sensibilities of the liberal
establishment to have somebody like
trump represent them.
Yes.
When it comes to genuine policy,
there's no difference between these
people.
It's just that the system wants people
who can make it more palatable and trump
makes it very unpalatable.
And so trump has woken us up,
but it unfortunately,
a lot of the liberal outreach has been a
trump personally rather than at the
policies,
and rather than at the system that he
represents no bursts or no better,
in fact,
you've represented more worse than,
you know,
uh,
even a Bush or Clinton or Obama
certainly can be much more effective in
representing the system.
And trump is.
And that's what Thompson is.
Trump's son is not in what he does.
Trump's son is in his personal
egregious.
I'm a in your face.
This function.
Is it that trump is not an anomaly.
Trump is revelation.
Trump reveal sales.
That's exactly what trump does.
And that's why they can't forgive him.
Yes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's right.
That's that personally I see it,
I think.
And by the end,
by the way I'm speaking of all of them
are traumatized people.
I'm an Obama was abandoned by his father
and he idealize this father in his book,
songs my father or,
or,
or I forget what the title of it was.
Something quite sentimental songs but,
but,
but he was a traumatized person.
And then his mother was a high troubled
individual and he was going to buy his
white grandparents.
He,
this guy suffered,
but he's.
He lacquered is suffering with this.
But with this pattern of,
of rationality.